There are two more software process models that I want to cover, so
bear with me. The first one is the Rational Unified software Process
or IUP, which is s a very popular one based on UML.
RUP works in an iterative way, which means it that it performs different
iterations. And at each iteration, it performs four phases. So what I'm
showing you here, is a high level view of the process. And I
don't want you to focus on all the different details, because we
will discuss these details later on, in a lesson that is actually dedicated
to RUP. What I want to give you now, is just the
gist of how this works. So, in each one of these four
phases, which I'm going to describe in a second. We perform standard software
engineering activities, the ones that we just discussed. And we do them
to different extent, based on the phase in which we are.
In particular, in the inception phase the work is mostly to sculpt
the system. So basically figuring out what is the scope of the
work, what is the scope of the project, what is the domain.
So that we can be able to perform initial cost
and budget estimates. The operational phase is the phase in which
we focus on the domain analysis and define the basic architecture
for the system. So this is a phase in which analysis
and design are particularly paramount. Then there is a construction phase,
which is where the bulk of the development actually occurs. And
as you can see here, is where most of the implementation
happens. And finally, the transition phase is the phase in which
the system goes from development into production, so that
it becomes available to users. And of course, this is
the phase in which the other activities in software
development become less relevant and deployment becomes the main one.